what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey this is
unwaxed
get in loser we're going shopping with
sophia and sistine stallone
everybody and welcome back to another
episode of unwax with your favorite
sisters
and sistine hello everybody happy
tuesday
thank you for listening in to another
week um
okay i just want to preface this episode
i'd like to start off this way
we've read your comments we understand
the sound quality is bad we are
embarrassed
we listen to it we're embarrassed but
guess what you guys
we are doing this over zoom and it's
covered
all of the studios are shut down and we
don't have a home studio are using
zoom audio if you want to see our setup
right now our computer is currently
stacked on a knife set
some random boxes our microphone which
isn't even attached
this is a problem tricking you is on my
mom's skincare products we are friends
so we're friends we know the audio it's
not
at this point i just felt more legit
with that but it's fine
the point is we know the audio sucks we
hear you
we appreciate you writing in but don't
give us less stars because yeah
that is not nice we hear you and you
can't hear
us doesn't mean we deserve a one star
all right
maybe three yeah at least at least
we upload our instagram um so if you
haven't
been able to tell if you're watching
this or not we're back in l.a
um and the journey to l.a was kind of an
interesting one and
right when it happened i thought i had
to share it on the podcast because it
was just so
random and of course it's something that
we would obviously run into
yeah so let me just start out fine we're
coming to the airport we're all ready to
go yep
bags are packed checked in we are
our we got our giant water bottles that
we usually get eating a sandwich but we
so we got hungry yeah we're excited
maybe they'll have a pickle sandwich
somewhere and guess what
they had a pickle sandwich so we looked
first we went to our gate and we saw
the screen and it said the time that our
flight would be
going but for some reason our brains we
thought it was when they were boarding i
don't know why we ever thought that
three people could not figure out that
the time of departure
was different than the time of boarding
we've gone to the airport
and we've done this yeah so it's just a
big brain fart on all of our parks
so we're sitting down we're eating our
sandwich thinking we have all of the
time in the world
um and we're just munching away enjoying
ourselves all of a sudden we get a tap
on our shoulder and this one
18 year old and a mom it looks like
comes up to us and goes
hi we're related we're stallone and i go
huh huh i think there's more there's
more there's more
but things we thought we knew everyone
from our family that it really that we
don't have like skeletons or closets and
family
we don't know about we know about all of
them but this one came from the stallone
side and she goes
i don't want to say her first and last
name like i'm going to call her
anna her name is like anna stallone and
i go
she goes i'm your cousin oh all righty
then cousin
cousin here we go where'd you come from
super sweet
she lives in florida
you know crazy right she's crazy so uh
we
started strolling up to our gate we
thought um seems like we've spent enough
time eating a sandwich it's time to go
no no you forgot a part what forgot
while we're eating our sandwich
a girl behind us goes hey i was
listening to you guys
did you go to usc and i go i did i
graduated 2018.
she goes i'm a freshman and then a guy
next to me
and goes fight on i'm an alum oh class
is 77.
what the [ __ ] is going on i was like
where are we going to all these people
at the smallest airport in florida
there's no one there that's funny
because it's like 20 go to the airport
to not socialize or talk to anyone
unless you're like that guy that says
like the chili's bar like don't be that
guy but if you are that's fine
but you know we go there not expecting
to see or talk to anyone
we just run into old family members we
run into some usc students alum
so we finish our sandwich and we go okay
we have a couple minutes let's go peruse
chili's yeah let's go to we have time
let's go to chile let's go chili's we've
got a chili's
check it out we got ooh yum yum all of a
sudden we come out of chili's we see our
gate and we see
um no one's people that are taking the
tickets to let us onto the plane and
there's no one there
like saying hurry up look at that
it's like let's go come on you're late
and i go am i late from across
and she goes yeah and we started
sprinting
and that's the place and he starts
laughing and they're like you know
you're the last ones on this flight
and we waited to open the doors but we
saw you guys earlier so we knew you were
in the airport we just knew you were
they were about to
go come find us so we thought oh my god
we made it
we're fine we're on the plane we're just
not going to tell jen and slide this
little story because they're going to
roast us
they're going to make fun of us and
they'll be like we can't navigate the
airport okay
so we think we're in the clear they come
home
yesterday and they land and the first
thing they say to us when they walk in
the kitchen again
again so we heard you almost missed your
flight all of the flight attendants
routed on you guys and told the
very story of us coming out of chili's i
mean
we got we got thrown under the
bus not just toss we got
slammed into it and so now my parents
think
we can't navigate the airport
fun good times come with us in other
news
a day has come that i never thought
would ever come
the day sophia joined a dating app
i know i know if you guys are avid
listeners you'd know sofia roasted me
hard for being on hinge and look at you
on it okay so
my sister has believed that my dating
life
is [ __ ] well it is it is
it's not great i i agree um
it's been a couple years since i've had
anything serious and
she thinks i need to get back on the
saddle you're gonna get on that
horseshoe but
i'm not a dating app person i've used
one before
as you guys know i tried it out for a
month
okay didn't work out the choices
no offense to anyone that's met anybody
on it not not for me i like in person i
like
getting this one but she's convinced me
she has
convinced me a lot it took a lot of
convincing
you guys this is what we're gonna do
we're gonna try to find sophia a day
we're going to take it back
old school on wax we're going to try to
find our day we're going to report back
how it went we're going to keep you guys
in the loop oh also
let's just mention something we've heard
around the crowd
that people are scared to date us now
yeah
because y'all think we're gonna talk
about you on the show
true but but let me explain this
just don't do anything bad don't if it's
an average date
we're not gonna say anything if it's a
great date you want
us to talk about it and if you do
something absolutely
terrible then of course we have to share
like
just like you so all you have to do is
just be an extremely average
person if we won't change this yeah make
it not amazing
yes but also make it not horrible
just be i know i feel like we're really
discovering ourselves with this thing
people actually are saying people are we
don't want to go out with you because
we're afraid
you're going to talk about us um but i
do it for the love of the listeners i
know you guys love it and also
if you guys tell me just right off the
bat like can you
not mention anything lose the fake news
we'll use a fake name of course we will
not mention you
we'll just pretend it was never you but
now we will we will respect privacy
on that note let's move on we are going
to do
an unsolicited advice we do have a guest
coming on but we're going to do this
before she comes on
and let's get right into it sophia do
you want to explain
how they can submit a question as you
guys know we love answering your
questions so
what you can do is go to apple podcast
go to the write a review section give us
that five stars
and write the question also a kind
comment because we love your comments
and we hear you
our audio sucks we get it we're not
happy but i have to say
since last week you guys have done a
really great job with that
yeah a lot more comments came through
shout out to all you guys who did it
correctly
we love you guys thank you so much let's
get into it we're gonna answer
two questions and we because we were
gonna decide on one of them but i think
we love both of them so
we'll answer the first one really quick
and it says i love your podcast i feel
like i've learned so much
and grown since listening anytime i go
through tough times i decide to listen
to unlocks and it gets my day 10 times
better
thank you you're so sweet but my name is
sophia
and i also have a question great name
what is your love language i'd love to
know this love you guys
and that's a great question because
christine and i have actually been
talking about wanting to do
part of a segment about love language
and why it's important actually to take
it because you learn a lot of things by
yourself
and the relationship you're in can i
guess yours and do you want to guess
mine yes
and i'll tell you what the answer is
okay that's fine i feel like yours
is a little bit
physical touch and words of affirmation
am i right yeah i actually have three oh
you got two of them right physical touch
words of affirmation
and i like quality no no it was the i
think
access or helping out accessories
accessories
yeah because i think i like physical
touch when it's not pda
i like just like the intimate like kiss
like i'm a very affectionate person
i like cuddling sometimes i like someone
telling me how they feel
i like someone telling me being
vulnerable vocalizing their emotions
with me
and i like when someone helps me out or
does something on the side that i didn't
even ask them to do and they just do it
what do you think
i think yours is um gifts
i think what do you think of that
challenge i
guess three gifts i'm going to say
physical touch
and words of affirmation you know you
really threw me off of the gifts one
i screenshotted it words of affirmation
quality time okay
uh receiving gifts was my lowest one you
were very wrong
thank you very much um no i think that
quiz is a little bit
whacked out though i think i need to
retake it i think we should reach it
because i took that literally like three
four years ago and i guarantee my
answers would be different now
but i do think if you guys ever are
looking to do something like that
definitely do it because and have your
partner do it too because you learn what
they like
and you learn what you like and it
becomes very symbiotic and the
relationship is better
moving on next question all right
question for cysteine and sophia
obviously i'm curious where you two plan
on taking the podcast
grow bigger on platforms slash more
youtube and do you have any other ideas
for ventures
you want to take on either together or
separately
oh that's a lot that's a heavy question
that's a lot of thank you elliot thomas
nation okay so where we plan on taking
the podcast
we talked about this a little bit last
week exciting things happening
we can't talk about it but sophie and i
do want to dabble in
merch and we sort of want to get into
that whole realm
yeah we're still trying to figure out
whether you guys could wear something
that says unwaxed on it because it is a
bit
aggressive we might need a logo maybe
we'll do a university
i would love to do that um sophia and i
also love the idea of uploading more on
youtube whether that's a vlog
or i don't know it's what i would you
guys like well actually please let me
know
what you guys would want out of this
even more so because we have some ideas
that
we've always talked about maybe vlogging
a bit or maybe showing some behind the
scenes not just of the podcast but what
we do in our day
and other adventures that we want to
take on like sophia i love
being off script and talking and
communicating with people so whether
that's
posting or or just being some sort of
tv presence we love that we also love we
also
love the idea of business in
not just the restaurant world but just
like this we love service we love
communicating with people and i don't
know maybe in the future we'll do
something like that
we're constantly formulating ideas and
yes we do have ideas separately that we
want to pursue but
right now we love working with each
other and i think numbers and powers and
at the moment we are pretty goddamned
and we haven't killed each other yet we
haven't killed you so
we're silly it's going great um i would
love to talk about the guests that we
have coming on today yes
her name is haley khalil she is a nasa
sports illustrated model
2021 she is so beautiful this
conversation is going to prove that you
can be
extremely smart and extremely beautiful
you don't have to have either one she is
incredible she is so funny and sweet and
i think you guys are going to love this
conference anything you guys are going
to gain just
an overall sense of happiness and glee
just because of how it's just [ __ ]
radiating yeah that's funny i hope you
guys like it and stay tuned
this minnesota native which we have
family in
went from minnesota immunology
laboratory to the pages of sports
illustrated she has made
everyone fall in love with her quirky
hilarious and honest personality
and continues to make waves in the
modeling worlds and signing with
wilhelmina am i correct with that
perfect yes so they were my first agency
yes yay i would love that
she started nerd hurt it was just
announced on being on si 2021
this is oh my god
i was like kind of weird i'm like let me
just check myself make sure i got all of
those things ready
wait you said wilhelmina was your first
agency are you yes so i am actually in
between agencies right now okay
so they were my first agency that i ever
signed with like i
shot an illustrated swimsuit for the
first time with no agency whatsoever
zero representing yourself hold on
that's pretty baller
that's really cool i felt like i was
like super ba i was like okay
like girl with no agent shoot an si this
is my first real model
she doesn't need help she got it herself
she does not need help
so i definitely needed some help but no
i mean you did it on your own anyway and
i would love to just talk about how
you transition from i could say maybe
two
extremely polar opposite jobs i mean you
did
study biomedical science and you're also
a sports illustrated model
how do those two worlds even collide for
you oh man it's been a weird transition
going from the medical world
to a world where somebody just only
looks at this like i used to be able to
walk into a room right and people would
be like okay what does she know you know
what's her laboratory training what is
her background
now i walk into a room and they're like
what are your measurements how tall are
you
and it's gone from like this one polar
extreme where they just viewed me based
on what i knew in my mind
to this other polar stream where they
beat me based on what this looks like
and so i'm trying hopefully to be an
advocate for combining the two
because as a human being we're more than
just this and we're more than absolutely
pissed
we're both at the same time so if we can
combine those two
and we can show the world you know who
we are and what we are we are
powerhouses that's so true because you
know i was saying to sistine that
i was reading all about you watching
interviews you're hilarious you're so
beautiful and you're really really smart
and i was
thinking that with our case sometimes
people
assume something they go okay they're in
the public eye they come from a famous
family and
i guarantee they're not hard working and
they're not very smart and they don't
care about school or
the community or anything but in
retrospect we actually do and do you
feel like you get a lot of frequency
notions now that you're in
the sports illustrated world or modeling
world
absolutely so when i first again it's
like when you first walk into a room as
a model which i am
not used to like it's been four years
it's intimidating i'm still not used to
it
when you walk into that room they expect
you just to be good at this
just know when you're angled being a
yeah
exactly like wow she's a beautiful
clothing hanger they don't expect
anything deeper than that
right there's no extra level to you as a
model and it's sad that people perceive
it that way
it is but i've been hoping to change
people's minds
so whenever i go to like a modeling
party or a gig or i'm on set i'm like
i am going to change people's minds like
so how do you change people's minds when
you're on set
i just try to have a conversation with
them like i love to get to know the
makeups artist journey to
you know finding her passion or his
passion the hair
artist journey the photographer's
journey and then once they talk about
their journeys i'm able to talk about
mine
and once i start talking about mine
they're like wait a second
she's a model but she was an
immunologist
and she's studying medicine these two
things are my favorite
they don't add up they don't know you
know it's what it sounds like it sounds
like you're not trying to prove to
people like i am smart i swear to god
because there is a difference between
proving to people you are smart but they
are just naturally showing right
i do i'm multifaceted i have a lot of
layers to me and
i think a lot of people need to do that
it's just really i think it also comes
from a state of
you're just very vulnerable and honest
you're just very but
and like tapping in on that being
vulnerable and honest
also i feel like ties into being very
confident and sure with yourself
and just talking to you right now and
seeing you on social media like
you exude this this bright light when
you're on on
the camera are you and you really do but
it obviously doesn't come naturally to a
lot of people so how did that sort of
come about
like what would you tell people if they
have to confidence
oh man so i'm i'm a huge nerd right like
everyone knows that
am a huge nerd i love it so am i do not
worry like i remember watching anime we
played video games like we built
bionicles when we were growing up like
glasses the dorky haircut that wasn't
like
nerd represent i love it thank you i
i always tell girls when they're like i
want to be a model how did you do it
what did you do and i'm like
i studied i studied i put in my time
i would look up every old school vintage
cindy crawford video heidi klum video
claudia schiffer video all of these like
amazing women that have pioneered the
modeling industry for women like me
i wanted to watch the way that they
moved the way that they communicated
with their eyes
their body their face and that's that's
how i learned
i mean i sat in front of a computer for
hours on end watching youtube videos
it's so funny because your background it
comes from studying and working hard in
the textbooks and now you're studying in
the modeling world so i think it's
really funny how you were able to
incorporate the two and you brought up
nerd heard a few times and i would love
to
explain to our listeners a little bit
more about what you do with that
so nerd was actually an initiative that
started on social media
that i was just kind of messing around
with so the backstory of nerd heard is
back in the day when i would go to all
my nerdy clubs
i have an older sister and you know
older sisters they love to give you crap
oh yeah i mean i love to give her are
you all giving me crap
i'm just perfectionist i just entered my
life too
like i was the captain of montreal as
the captain of chess club like duct tape
pup you name it
that was me that was me girl so my
sister would always be like oh
haley's going off to nerd her like she's
going off to her nerd herd
and so that was always kind of a
derogatory statement for me and about my
feelings
so then when i got older and realized
that your intellectual presence is power
i was like nerd is not an insult nerd
herd is such a compliment like if
somebody says you're part of the nerd
hurt i'm like
heck yes i am so you're very proud it's
it's really empowering for women just to
own their brain
you unfortunately the times that we live
in now
i feel like all women are sort of just
looked at as
one tier below and they're never looked
at for their intelligence it's always
about what's on the outside how skinny
does she look on the red carpet like oh
her hair looks nice but no one ever
questions
oh she actually wrote that movie like
yeah oh she actually that came out of
her brain so i think it's really cool
yeah and then you know also sounds like
it sounds like your confidence comes
from knowledge of you just saying
i know who i am i know what i know and
i'm just gonna own that and i feel like
people
it's like you don't really put that
together because people just say oh like
fake it till you make it
or yeah um confidence yeah like or
confidence just comes naturally and you
just have to believe it and then you'll
have it but i really think it's
which isn't true i think no i think it's
all about knowledge if you
really know who you are you really own
what you know and then you love what you
love
and it just that's what comes naturally
and it seems like that's what you do
very fluidly well thank you i mean i am
grateful that i have
my backstory i have two engineers as
parents so
oh my gosh so you're very meticulous
about everything
so when i was like i want to be a model
they were like there's no way in heck
there's no way yeah you are going into
the sciences so
i'm thankful that my mother always told
me there's nothing more powerful than an
intelligent woman and that always stuck
with me
because my mom used to say that to me
that
no that's true there's one thing that no
one can ever
take away from you is your education
exactly and so that is something
a hundred days this is what's inside 100
percent so i love this movement that
you're starting you're preaching this
it's such a good message
i want to talk a little bit about your
sports illustrated photos because
holy cow please drop your butt routine
your body
is chest beautiful so beautiful oh my
god what did you do to prepare
how long did you train before or was
there even any training are you just
genetically gifted
i mean my mom my mom weighs like 100
pounds just
naturally yeah so i get that from my
mother i can thank her for that
but the great thing about sports
illustrated swimsuit which a lot of
people don't know
is there's this saying around the models
that usually when you get booked for a
job you're like oh no i need to cut down
on what i eat
i need to make sure that my body looks
perfect the running joke is book sports
illustrated eat a hamburger
like be yourself that's why they're an
entire
sport illustrated is totally changing
the narrative and they're like we want
all body types we don't want victoria's
secret stick figures
okay so that's awesome like they want
you
you still looked incredible so what did
you do
i still like need your workout because
you have you you probably i think i read
that you do like light workouts like
wait
i do it so every day i just think that a
healthy lifestyle breeds a healthy mind
which creates a healthy everything right
we work out every day just for our
mental health yeah like
it sounds good yeah especially right now
it's like we have so many stressors in
the world like the world is crazy right
now so there's
nothing better than getting like a good
sweater like
you just absolutely like if something's
pissing you off you're like i'm just
gonna get everything out of me like
right now so
it's so good it builds endorphins it's
the best yes
and so i um i also have some health
conditions so i couldn't eat certain
foods so i thought okay this is a great
time during quarantine to like
get my diet on track to get my workouts
on track to start drinking more water
because i was drinking literally zero
chemicals in a can so it's sort of those
those were my favorite chemicals in hand
so it's sort of just
your natural healthy lifestyle just it
wasn't hard for you to prepare it it
sort of just came
easy it was it was definitely easy as
far as like once you have your healthy
lifestyle down that's hard to do though
oh my goodness because i love
consistencies so much
are you kidding me what are the little
like cinnamon sugar
like bread uh the one of the dumplings
the yeah
in the icing yes
get out of here yeah no
hold on but you treated yourself to a
lava cake after the shootout
and i remember walking in once i booked
sports illustrated again because the
funny thing about sports illustrated
swimsuit is
no one knows who's gonna be in it it is
all a mystery
like no even the cover model doesn't
know she's the cover model
until like two days before like they are
i like
that though yeah it just makes it much
more exciting and crazy
yeah oh my god and wait you went through
like a couple challenges i didn't
realize
uh there's like the rookie and then
there's something else and there's this
there's like a lot of tears layers to
them i didn't realize it takes like a
really long time to get to the cover
every year that you're back is like an
extra like
oh my goodness yes like like i'm closer
to the top
cool every time i get the call i would
bawl my eyes out i'm like
yes another year and when i got the call
this year i ran over to my trainer and i
was like
the give me a butt like how do we get it
let's go you're like i need it
i
is there something you have to tell
yourself do you ever like look in the
mirror is there a pep talk you tell
yourself before
oh you're like okay he's getting in a
bikini i got to be so what do you do
around the beach what do you tell
yourself i'm like every time which
sounds so silly
i imagine if they picked me for cover
what that photo would look like
and what i'd wanted to look like and i
was like you know what i'd want it to be
the best version of me
which means i have to put in the amount
of work necessary
to like imagine myself on the cover of
sports illustrated
so every single year that's what i do
i'm like i'm going to just
imagine what i think a cover sports
illustrate my head if i was on it
and i want to be that version of myself
you're manifesting it yeah
a lot of things like if you go into a
situation and you picture like
this is where it's going even if it's
not for that you're like this is what it
is like
this is how i'm you're going to behave
that way and i think that that's a
really good like
mental preparation yeah just to get you
in that mode
well it's funny because last year when
olivia culpo landed one of the covers
because there were three girls on the
cover
yeah she had an entire board where she
actually cut out pictures
and pasted them over old covers of
sports illustrated
and it was a manifestation board and
it's like there's oh she she
did that and now she actually has a copy
of sports illustrated where she is the
cover girl
that's small so i need to start doing
this so why don't we do that i'm going
to start
myself out putting it on vogue
so i i am known as like the hopeless
romantic of the group and i know that
you're married and you have a husband
um his name is matt right and you guys
how long have you guys been married
five years i'm married i'm like an old
married lady
well you don't look like an old married
lady
i had it okay so i heard there was a
funny story about how you actually met
him
like he and i are such a sucker we love
the first time meeting and we love like
the first impressions and like what
what was it for you guys so long story
short i actually met this guy on tinder
not my husband different guy i met him
it's funny you say that because
i just convinced sofia to join a dating
app so the fact that you just met him on
tinder
i told you unhinged i told you you win
anyway please
do the good one hey but you were on
tinder for
him you met see she's laughing she
didn't meet him on tinder
i did the house
the date was it was horrible it was like
the worst date ever
why was it so bad it was so we
there was this little joint in minnesota
i was like 20
no i was probably younger than 20 i was
probably like 19. and it had an
elevator that like went up to this
rooftop restaurant and i had just met
this man
like just met him and he tried to like
christian gray me in the elevator
and i was like bro no no it's been a
second
no no like this i know it looks cool in
the movie but no
no no so after that like ordering
appetizers after you have to like
stop a guy from trying to kiss you when
you just met him in an elevator
so not the best situation not the best
scenario
not the best so then the entire time
during the dinner
he kept saying oh my best friend lives
right down the road like he was right my
best friend he's so amazing but he was
right down the road and i was like
i feel like this is my out like why
don't you invite your best friend
like i want to meet him because it's
awkward between the two of us
and that best friend was my husband
so if he hadn't tried to christian grow
you in the elevator and if it hadn't
gone terribly and if he hadn't offered
to hang out with his friend you wouldn't
have met your husband
yeah you need to do stuff like this we
need to get out of the house i think
that's the first step
this is a great story i made fifty
shades of grey
for my marriage like i feel like i need
to get them
what do you think is the key though
because you guys have been together for
a while and now you're married what do
you think was the
three key things that helped building a
healthy
relationship because i know every
relationship has its ups and downs like
nothing's perfect
but what is a really good thing that
people should know when they're
getting into a relationship and they're
like in a relationship that they should
remember
i think it's staying true to who you are
is the first like being completely
and utterly yourself like don't move
yourself to be
like that person said they love you more
like i remember it
doing that
so he likes um i don't know some weird
movie thing so i'll start liking that
like i'll start liking this
right and all these things that he likes
that he falls in love with me
with my husband i was like i'm gonna be
completely and totally myself
like that's the first thing i'm going to
be like completely authentic
me beautiful i got it i'm like i'm going
to go to bed with like toothpaste on my
face if i'm breaking out like i'm just
going to be
i'm not going to be like the cute like
always perfect yeah like always looking
good and dressing well like i'm gonna be
a
hot mess which is what i am 99 of the
time
so this is not normal like this is not
like this is cruel this morning like i
know this took hours
no but i love that it's it's that's just
it's so authentic
it's being natural being yourself
initially right off the bat and
continuing that
and communication is second
communication is like me if you do not
have that communication especially
because him and i are a long distance a
lot of the time because of our work
it's done like if you can't communicate
like you might as well like
wave that white flag like what's your
form of commit you face timing a lot is
that how you're doing it face time just
communicating about your day
communicating your feelings like if
you're feeling a certain way say it even
if it's gonna like hurt the other
person's feelings
even if it's hard to say don't bury that
deep down because in marriage over time
it just like
because yeah there's times i feel like i
i feel like i don't know if you're like
this too but when you feel a certain way
and you don't say it
it kind of comes out in other ways
you're passive aggressive throughout the
week and we also we just worry so much
about not hurting their feelings and
then they would rather us hurt their
feelings in the moment right then
exactly it's like when you think it's a
sign of maturity
yeah that's a sign of maturity that's
true yeah
and he was being like weird and acting
passive aggressive i'd be like what's
wrong
and he didn't feel like i'm fine and i'd
be like no what's wrong
what's wrong what's wrong here yeah
that's such good advice that's such good
advice
sophia and i wrote up some rapid fire
questions that
you just answer real quick or you could
go you know what it's your game you can
answer as long as you want yeah okay
here's the first one
jerry's like most romantic thing you've
ever done
uh six flags vip tour
flags that is great that is great all
right next one
what does your cheat day look like my
taco bell
lava cakes from domino chicken and cream
cheese puffs
boom wow that was the answer of the year
this might even be the same one what is
your guilty pleasure
taco bell
with cream jesus that's amazing
wait what is the cream cheese puff what
is this this must be a minnesotan thing
because whenever i get out here in new
york everyone's like
what it's like like the ragoon
the crab right but with no crab yes i've
had this before it's like a
pastry and there's just crab in it
yeah i've seen this i would go to
minnesota for one of those for sure yeah
make sure you go during the summer do
not go down got it
oh absolutely not the winner okay if you
could have a song
play every time you entered a room what
would it be
oh my god i'm trying to see the world
that i've been listening to recently
um it would probably be beyonce song i
don't know which one
because it's like there's so many good
ones but a beyonce song would be like
i am here type of freaking moment yeah
like
this flawless wake up like flawless
for humor though i would definitely like
wow to play
just like as a like oh that would be so
fabulous
fabulous you're just like what's up
what's up oh now let's go
okay i feel like i know the answer to
this next one what's one word to
describe yourself in high school
nerdy and weird
what's a childish thing you still do as
an adult legos
we love that we watch that's why it's
built by articles
there's different kinds of legos what
are we talking about like millennium
falcon
adult adult lego set that's what i mean
yeah yeah yeah it's so much fun to
construct
because well you're kind of a scientist
so i get that
you like look at it
okay so if you could do one thing in the
world besides being
a super hot engineer and a model what
would it be
i would be a reconstructive surgeon
oh cool i like that that was like my
ultimate goal
was reconstructive surgery so like
reconstructing people
who have been in accidents or people who
have lost their breasts because of
breast cancer
things like that like it's art which is
what i do now yeah mixed with
science and medicine yeah that's what i
used to do and it's like
it changes people's lives when i really
wake up and go like you just made me the
most confident person now
exactly it's like you're able to make an
impact on somebody's life in a way that
they will never forget
well it's not too late you can always i
know there you go i can always go back
take out another career why don't you
just do it i'm just gonna sign up for
medical school
while i'm trying to be you know a model
while i'm doing all these other things i
got this
you got this i just knew kelly we're
good your plate is so small like you
have nothing going on already
like just just go for it you know you're
done
haley you're inspired though oh my god i
hope so thank you so much
today you are so much fun and like
honestly you just made me so energized
with your personality so thank you so
much beautiful smile
thank you thank you guys oh my god of
course
tell our listeners where they can find
your instagram all of that stuff
well hey guys thank you so much for
listening to me
blab on about how nerdy i am but you can
find me at
haley h-a-l-e-y-y bailey b-a-y-l-e-e on
instagram
and on tick tock and on twitter
oh i will be following you on twitter
i'll see you there
i love the tick tock follow me back
oh my god it was so good to meet you
hopefully we can keep each other
i know right once quarantine is over
lego date let's go
yes in bye bye bye guys
thank you